In this world, there are many relationships and roles such as parent and child, friends, etc., and I think
each person plays a role or wishes the other person to do the same.The
names of the roles can be expressed in completely different words depending on the person,
so we can also say things like husband and wife, who are given the death penalty.
But there's
no need to be too strict about that.
[Music]
You don't want to be cast in the role of my wife or teacher. If
anything, I
'd like that.  No,
but
[Music] No matter how it
started,
[Music] No matter what
role I play, I'm
happy to be by your side, and I'm
happy that you think you can't let me go. I'm
happy.
"  I feel like I'll be able to
get through tomorrow somehow.If I have these
memories, even if things get a little tough, I'll be able to make it through.I feel
better, or rather, my insides are buzzing.
[Music]
Well, now that I'm able to talk to you,  I'm happy, and I'm
sad to go back to bed.I'm
probably thinking that I'm happy to be playing the role of a married couple with you right now.That's
why I don't mind continuing to play this role.Honestly, I
don't mind if you say you don't like it, but I'm
still a teacher.  I also continue to do so.